Android patterns for performance
So you are a hardworking person
Watch each episode of Android Performance Patterns.
Not every episode because Colt offers a lot of episodes
Usually things say,
Such as do not overuse the battery.
Make effective HTTP requests.
Censuses are similar to mechanical failures.
All normal performance issues.
You now know that you do not want a bulky APK package.
You do not want unnecessary resources in your edition.
But even though you know this, you may still have a bloated APK package.
So how was this possible?
I'm David East.
And your resource economy
It does not mean that the libraries you have listed will be economical as well.
Here is this common scenario.
You are using the Google Play services library
To create an application that uses a single API package such as Maps.
But your code instructions do not use them in logon functions.
The library still includes all assets and charts
Which allows people to sign in.
Although you may be impressed by this button,
You do not need the resource in the APK package.
Because you can not remove the resource manually,
It is included in the final package application.
These are the things that produce inflated APK packages.
This problem can be resolved by using the Gradle toolkit.
Gradle can analyze all your code instructions
To find assets that do not have a reference
Then automatically remove them from your edition.
It does not stop here.
Gradle will examine and analyze the strings in your code
For situations where you do things like create a path name at run time
It will also browse your asset folder,
Open text files, CSS and JavaScript files
Check them out too.
To start this, simply enable the Resource Shrink tag
In the automatic configuration of your Gradle. You'll also need to enable miniaturization.
This will trigger the Proguard that removes the code
From linked libraries that your app does not use.
Be aware that this must be done first.
Otherwise Gradle will get involved a lot
Because it is still believed that there are assets passed through the reference.
After that, things will get much better.
After connecting Google Play services,
Gradle sees that there are no paths using login resources
And exclude them from your APK package,
That is precisely what we wanted.
But there is a simple warning.
That there may be negative or positive results.
You may find that some of your assets
They are cut when you want to keep them
You find assets to be retained when you want to cut them.
We can solve this by using SMTY accepting and rejecting tools
To set the desired behavior.
But before cutting resources,
It is important to realize that Gradle has limitations.
Gradle will not get rid of the precision folders
Or multi-language folders.
This may be needed at run time
Because the compiler does not know early what the end user will need.
Managing your resources requires some extra effort on your part,
But this will be a great performance gain for your user.
User experience is the primary goal of performance.
Find out more by watching the rest of Android Performance Patterns
Any Colt program.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
For another great content as well.
Consider small things but do not panic.
Always remember that performance is important.